[Music]
we have studied the two types of magnets
in our past videos permanent magnets and
temporary magnets do you remember
them this is how one can Define them in
simple words please take a moment and go
through these
definitions we will talk about the
temporary magnets
first these are magnets that retain
their magnetism only for a short amount
of time or only until they are kept
under an external magnetic
field when removed from the external
magnetic field they lose their
magnetism we have seen the two easy
processes used to make temporary magnets
we used objects made up of ferromagnetic
material such as an iron nail and an
iron bar what do we know about magnets
we know that a magnet attracts magnetic
objects like like ion and attracts or
repels other magnets do you know what
this property is called this property of
magnets to attract or repel is called
magnetism look at the example we saw
what is happening here is that the two
objects are acquiring magnetism through
their
processes so these objects weren't
magnets they acquired
magnetism this process through which any
non-magnetic object acquires the
property of magnetism is called
magnetization yes
magnetization this can also be defined
as a process to magnetize any
non-magnetic object so in these
processes we are magnetizing the
ferromagnetic
objects now there is one more way in
which we can magnetize these
objects and that is by understanding
that electric current generates a
magnetic field first let's Enlighten
ourselves about this
in 1819 there was a scientist named Hans
Christian
Ed he found out that if you keep a
compass near a current carrying wire
then the compass needle deflects to some
extent yes understand this well when
current passes through this wire and we
keep this Compass near that wire the
needle will
deflect this will not work if the
current in the wire is
feeble however in that case if we remove
move a part of the insulated coating and
keep the compass near that region you
will see the
deflection now we know for a fact that
if we keep this Compass at rest away
from any other magnet then it will align
itself in the direction of the Earth's
magnetic field that is the red part will
point in the north Direction while the
other part will point in the South
Direction what will happen if we bring
any magnet near this Compass well if we
bring the North Pole of a bar magnet
near the red needle the needle will show
deflection the needle now aligns itself
in the direction of the magnetic field
of this bar
magnet we know that in a bar magnet the
field line emerg from the North Pole
curve around the magnet and end at South
Pole so if we move the compass in the
direction of the magnetic field then its
needle will also align itself in the
direction of the
field with this knowledge in mind let's
go back to a copper wire here the
electric current in the wire produces
magnetic field around the wire or in
other words the wire becomes a temporary
magnet this is the reason that the
compass needle deflects when brought
near this
wire but how exactly will the compass
needle align itself if moved in the
surrounding or in other words what is
the direction of the magnetic field
produced by electric current in the wire
keep watching on videos to know the
[Music]
answer